i want to start today by talking about
president joe biden's upcoming supreme
court pick as many of you have no doubt
heard by now uh the oldest liberal
justice on the court stephen breyer is
going to be retiring and joe biden is
going to get to pick or nominate rather
a replacement which is subject to
confirmation by the senate now joe biden
made a promise during the campaign
that he would select a black woman which
would be if confirmed the first black
woman ever on the united states supreme
court um he confirmed that that's still
the plan gen saki his white house press
secretary confirmed it and i believe joe
biden has also been asked about it and
confirmed that as well
the american right
is now starting a campaign
to make the case that this is extremely
discriminatory and essentially racist to
anyone who is not a black woman in other
words the way that many are framing it
and we're going to look at laura ingram
in a moment who's doing this is
if you are excluding anyone who is not a
black woman it is by definition
discriminatory and or racist against
those individuals um
this is wacky and as someone who is not
a wokester and not into corrosive
identity politics i'm gonna explain to
you why these people are wrong but let's
first listen to laura ingram like
everything else joe biden touches his
supreme court selection process is in
shambles
candidate biden he thought he was being
really woke and so cool by pledging to
nominate an african-american woman to
the high court but of course he was also
effectively discriminating against a
vast majority of the adult population
uh-oh and now even liberal websites like
slate thinks he has himself in a bind
claiming that biden's pledge is
backfired and needlessly tokenized
future nominees so let me remind you
i am
not an identity politics guy i have
spoken out for a decade about uses of
identity to silence
or to um
exclude
you all if you've been watching this
show listening to my podcast for a while
you know that
um let's go through this now in that
context in steps first of all is what
joe biden is doing
unique and the answer is no it is not
here is donald trump saying
i'm choosing between women only for this
next seat and the crowd cheered
i will be putting forth the nominee next
week it will be a woman
right
uh it wasn't only donald trump who did
this ronald reagan did the exact same
thing paul's continuing to show he runs
better among men than women reagan took
a dramatic step today to reach out for
female support
now i'm announcing today that one of the
first supreme court vacancies in my
administration
will be filled by the most qualified
woman i can possibly find oh whoa hold
on a second now you can say well they
were all wrong to do that david okay
fine you could take that position
but were you actually saying it at the
time or are you saying it now
that they already put women on the
courts and you no longer
really have to say anything about it
it's very easy now to say well they were
all wrong none of them should have done
it but that's not really the most
important thing to think about i'm
putting for context that this is not
unique so a lot of the criticism of
biden is hypocritical but the the most
important thing is the context that
matters here the supreme court was
established in 1789.
from 1789 until 1967
that's
178 years
every single justice
was
white
and male
okay
178 years and during that time we had
slavery in the united states for roughly
80 years of that 178 years we had
slavery of black people and an all-white
male court so it's okay and it's notable
when we say hey we now have a black
person on the court
which came in 1967 with thurgood
marshall it's not racist it's not
discriminatory it's look at the makeup
of the country and look at the makeup of
the court and at this point with so many
qualified black jurists how have we not
had one it's okay to point that out
you're not participating in toxic and
corrosive identity politics let's give
another example from 1789 until 1981 we
had all men on the court that's
192 years every single justice was a man
so it's okay and notable to say
given the history of qualified
women lawyers judges here's finally the
first woman on the court uh when sandra
day o'connor was nominated to the court
there has never been an asian person on
the supreme court native american
pacific islander black woman indian
american et cetera we don't need a court
that exactly matches the makeup of the
us in every turn every every sort of
demographic characteristic nor is it
even possible with only nine people on
the court but at a certain point when
you say wow we have 330 million people
in the country now
the supreme court's been around more
than 200 years it starts to get weird
that we have not had certain people on
the court
now they start to play its identity over
qualifications they say we're ignoring
who are the most qualified people
because we're focused on identity
instead of qualifications and again
that's a terrible argument once again
we're a country of 331 million people
if i were to say or if joe biden were to
say
i am going to pick the first former
sports oh
okay current or former sports team owner
who is a woman we would say wow that's
like a really small group there's not a
lot of female major sports team owners
it's like you know renee montgomery and
michelle williams from destiny's child
is a part owner of a team and jeannie
buss owns parts of multiple nba teams we
might be saying that's really weird that
identity designation
is not
uh appealing to appearing to be a pool
of qualified people
joe biden is picking one black woman and
there are many qualified black women
there is no reason to believe
that by saying i'm going to pick a black
woman and it's going to be notable given
the history of the country in the
history of the court there's no reason
to believe that it's going to be a less
qualified individual you're picking from
among the many qualified black women it
is such a non-story
and that's me as a non-woke
non-identity person non-identity
politics person telling you this but
they're going to keep playing it up
and they're going to make it into
something that it is not if you disagree
with me i would love to hear from you um
respectfully of course
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chili sleep has a special offer just for
my audience go to chillysleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below